ich weiß was er denkt es ist freitag das
heißt eigentlich müssten heute die
komanis kommen aber ich hab was anderes
cooles in minecraft gefunden und zwar
auf eine minecraft server mit anderen
leuten und zwar von meinem guten kumpel
nick iii pc steht in der beschreibung
ich gebe einfach mal einen / john und
damit bin ich quasi direkt drin und muss
jetzt hier andere punkte einsammeln und
kam dadurch quasi meine größe maximieren
ihr seht schon da desto mehr leute ich
bin tot
ich bin gut ich gebe wieder ein / john
und ich glaube sogar wenn ich immer fünf
wurdest bin und rein theoretisch main
echo wie mal so ganz hoch mache dann ist
das sogar eigentlich noch viel einfacher
oder also dann sehe ich ja direkt werden
leute kommen oder wenn nicht und ja
dementsprechend jedenfalls sehen damit
meinen score das heißt findet bei 22 23
kommt drauf an desto mehr von den
kleinen punkt nicht halt fresse und man
sieht halt nicht direkt welchen score
die anderen haben bzw
man sieht es halt rechts in dieser
tabelle dadurch den und ich habe dabei
spreche 21 das heißt ich sehe wenig
fressen kann nicht ist ein bisschen
kompliziert als dario fo
allerdings dachte ich mir dass ich hab
mir mal gegessen kontrakt wieder ein f
ich bin ja so nice triple drei stück
habe ich gerade gefressen guck mal hier
drin bin ich wieder richtig gut schon
wieder zwei gefressen was mir nicht den
fünf bar aus hier bin ich wie folgt in
dem normalen niveau war ich mal voll
scheiße habt ihr wahrscheinlich auch ein
video gestern gerade wieder gesehen
aber es ist doch nicht wahr das ist doch
voll nice gerade das läuft doch richtig
hier guck mal den hier vorne fresse
jetzt auch eben den ring ich jetzt eben
eine innere enge und dann ist ganz easy
hier zu 300 stunden wieder an double
habe gerade unwillkürlich unfreiwillig
herausgekommen dass man sich blicken
kann und zwar bin ich jetzt zwei teile
das sieht man eventuell jetzt bin ich
wieder ein das habe ich nicht wieder 370
und jetzt kann ich rein theoretisch wenn
ich sage ich möchte irgendwann von euch
fressen kann ich einfach space drücken
so jetzt bin ich 183 dann steht auch
kurz pid und jetzt bin ich schneller und
jetzt wohlig gefressen
der hat eine sache von mir gefressen
kicker was bildet sie ein
ich bin von crafter ich will gewinnen
dachte mir halt so ganz einfach ja
normalerweise kommen heute die minecraft
command also irgendwas cooles was
minecraft geschaffen wurde ohne dass man
in welchem maß dafür installieren
braucht allerdings dachte ich mir dass
das hier recht ähnlich ist das ist in
minecraft man muss keine mods
installieren gerade kommt die sonne
es unterscheide ich bin ich gleich total
überlastet was mir auch aufgefallen ist
man verliert mit der zeit seine größte
schaut dann bin ich kein es geht das auf
205 runter jetzt gehts auf 200 400 das
heißt man muss mit der zeit welche
fressen einfach die solche findet man
schon ideen kann nicht fressen den kann
nicht fressen einfach damit man nicht
quasi einfach herum stehen kann und
irgendwie läuft immer werden sich rein
oder irgendwie fest doch der hat mich
gegessen du kleiner bastard dich kriege
ich noch einfach damit halt keiner
simpel rumstehen und abwarten kann und
danach irgendwann der ersten der liste
ist und ich bin sogar 12 36 fünfter
sechster siebter irgendwie sowas black
mamba is coming for me
du kriegst bin ich niemals jetzt
rechtlich emails lesen
da kommt wieder die black mamba was will
die denn dir dich es sich auf 7001 ich
bin dritter
ich bin was ich bin der star ich sprinte
gerade ne ich bin maler fucking am
sprinten alter komme ich biete mich
jetzt bin ich 1700 hier und bin immer
noch größer als der zweite tor wenig
krass ich bin der riesige also es ist
nicht so dass das was neues für mich
wäre wenn ich irgendwie das größte hätte
oder der größte bin oder der geilste
oder der behaarten schnauze 3000 marking
458 war mein score geht runter weil ich
kein fresse und jetzt kommen hier der
hsfk gerade den fress mal eben hier
dicht vorne hier den dichter
ich bin tot
ich fresse hier direkt wieder zackig
schon direkt wieder auf 56 30 hier noch
ein paar davon dass definitiv für groß
für mich dann heute noch oder schon
wieder der etwas größere da die sind
auch alle rechtlich wichtig fresse ich
noch eben hier die ich bin ich bin schon
wieder mandat fucking tod also dieses
spiel ist definitiv schnelllebiger als
das normale agrio weil hier einfach so
alles zu schnell ist und die map ist
relativ klein und man kann immer sehr
schnell gefressen werden aber ihr so
einer wie ich es natürlich hier zeigt
die recht bin ich bin schon wieder tot
ich habe mir einfach gedacht es passt
halt heute zum freitag also
normalerweise wirklich in den comments
ich stelle sachen vor die man in
minecraft vanilla machen kann ohne
irgendwie großartig ich bin mods zu
kennen oder irgendwas dazu zu
installieren oder whatever
ich bin spieler über 174 das ganze
gerade und dann dachte ich bin bei 230
das ist auch ganz neu sondern dachte ich
mir einfach ja oh das ist eine kreation
von einem kumpel von mir den ich also
das heißt kumpel von mir mit dem ein
paarmal gestehen weimar gezeigt und man
kann es ganz simpel zocken einfach auf
dem server für alle bleiben viele haben
diese probleme dass die auf dem server
gehen und dann steht da einfach des
website ist block because of firewall
oder virus oder whatever
und ich hatte das beispielsweise
bielefeld bei meinen eltern da war das
irgendwie beim router aber dafür
eingestellt das ist nicht gegen das ist
nicht zocken konnte deswegen ist das ihr
das für alle die irgendwie fehler haben
oder das nicht hinkriegen so wie ich und
ich weiß auch schon ganz schnell ganz
oben wieder in den in den links hier in
den charts sag ich mal in dem
leaderboard deswegen ist das ganz neues
eigentlich also ich finde man könnte auf
jeden fall mal testen könnt ausschenken
das ist kostenlos es ist nicht ihr müsst
keine großen skills erbärmlich wird halt
euch halt einfach empfehlen das sowieso
einzustellen wie es gerade halt getan
habe und wie ihr seht ich bin schon
wieder jetzt in den top fünf top 6
irgendwie sowas um den dreh ich bin
gerade schon wieder verrückt aber mit
dem video verzeiht mir bitte dass keine
commands tawern sondern dieses videos
oft es hat es trotzdem gefallen zeigt
man mit einer bewertung ruf